on your math quiz you earn five points
for each question that you answer
correctly in the table below X
represents the number of questions that
you answer correctly and Y represents
the total number of points you score on
your quiz fair enough
the relationship between these two
variables can be expressed by the
following equation y is equal to 5x
graph the equation below so you could
look at a couple of your points you
could say well look if I got 0 questions
right I'm going to have 0 points so you
could literally graph that point if I
got 0 questions right I get 0 points and
then if I get one question right the
table tells us that or we could
logically think about it every question
I get right I'm going to get 5 more
points so if I get one question right
I'm going to get 5 more points and we
saw that in our table as well we saw
that right over here 1 question 5 points
we could also plot it 2 questions 10
points any of these but you only only
have to do two points to define a line
so it looks like we are actually done
here